The Joe Rogan Experience you know
functional strength exercises that's a
real weight right Joe
I think so yeah everybody made fun of me
because of the Chris Cuomo thing man
yeah I thought it was real I just I'm
being naive I guess but eventually I
looked at I go yeah that is kind of
weird how you can move it around like
that yeah just like a [ __ ]
paperweight so that guy's fire now I got
rid of that dude yeah wow wait and we're
for a weird reason I mean not weird like
ethically I get it because he helped his
brother and his brother I get I don't
know how he helped his brother like what
did he do his brother was getting they
were people were accusing him of sexual
harassment and so did he like do
research on the people that is that what
he did I remember reading he texted
someone who like knew of the situation
like what do you got on someone and oh
that's it I don't know if that's it I
just should use signal yeah
[Laughter]
or call the guy I mean oh yeah it's uh
he probably didn't think anything of it
he probably did it on Instinct but yeah
he's done what does a guy like that do
when you get fired from somebody I don't
know I thought that guy was like immune
to everything
well I think CNN is realizing that their
ratings are dog [ __ ] yeah and that
having these highly polarizing editorial
personalities like stelter and Don Lemon
and you know Michael Mouse is [ __ ]
hilarious you know what he did he put up
he goes now that Chris Cuomo's gone
who's the alpha male over at CNN he put
up a poll and everybody said to Anderson
Cooper
I think Anderson Cooper came in first
yeah but it's like these they it's I I
personally maybe maybe this is just my
bias I want
the news I want objective news I want
someone to tell me what are the facts of
what's going on and what's happening I
don't want your ideological slant I
don't want this left-wing propaganda
Network which is what CNN's become the
way I look at CNN now is so differently
than the way I looked at CNN 15 20 years
ago yeah I used to look at them as like
this is how I get the news this is
unbiased professional news they're going
to tell me what's happening in Pakistan
and what's happening in you know
Mogadishu this these are this is these
are the real journalists that are
telling you the news now I look at them
I go you [ __ ] propagandists like what
do you the right arm of Pfizer like what
are you doing yeah you know it's just uh
I think there's a market for real news
and it's really hard to find that now
it's really hard especially outside of
independent sources yeah
yeah and I guess if you're trying to
even take a balanced approach to things
like are you even gonna be they're gonna
be censored to the point where you can't
even be a news Outlet to begin with
right so